losing a friend making a choice to hold
your ground to save your family
as far as last stanz go ask the one-out
pick
he picked it too
hey guys pete here with less than two
weeks to go until the premiere of the
expanse's sixth and final season on
amazon prime video i thought i'd put
together a new video that recaps
everything you need to know going in a
sort of series recap in terms of how did
we get here why is this happening and
then i'll be going over where things
were left at the end of season five and
what that means we should expect from
season six if you aren't caught up with
all five seasons of the expanse then
this video will contain spoilers that
you might not want to see and that's
your warning now let's get into it
the first five seasons of the expanse
involved a lot of major changes taking
place in our solar system in the 24th
century as a result of extreme damage to
the planet's ecosystem the un now
governs the entire planet earth which as
the birthplace of humanity tries to hold
on to its dominant role in political
affairs mars has emerged as a military
power after earning its independence on
the heels of its invention of the
epstein drive which is what made
colonization possible in the first place
and the belt or the space beyond the
inner planets is now populated with an
exploited class of workers whose bodies
have been altered after generations of
growing up in low gravity the discovery
of the proto-molecule on phoebe led to
conflict as the different powers tried
to harness its potential to improve
their position for the now extinct
ancient alien civilization that created
it it was a tool they used to build
interstellar roads they sent it out to
distant solar systems to hijack the life
there and build ring gates these gates
are then connected to the ring network
through the hub that the characters
refer to as the slow zone based on what
happened there when they first passed
through soul gate the ring builder
civilization used the gates to expand
their empire in the milky way right up
until the time they came under attack
from a different civilization we call
the unknown aggressors in an effort to
survive which obviously didn't work
since you know they're extinct they shut
down the ringgate network and it
remained their idol waiting for someone
to discover it our solar system turned
out to be an anomaly in their plan
because the proto-molecule that was sent
here got captured by saturn's gravity
and it never made it to earth to hijack
the primitive life that existed there at
that time humanity evolved and then
billions of years later we discovered
this substance that was waiting on
phoebe and then it connected our
civilization to the ring network we
passed through the gate and now through
that hub of ring gates humanity has
access to 1 373
systems which based on the whole
hijacking of the life that would have
been there and the extinction of the
civilization behind that are essentially
full of ready-made worlds that are ripe
for population free land and free
resources for the taking a gold rush
waiting to happen for every step of this
progression the crew of the rasanante
have found themselves in the middle of
things the discovery in julie mao's
infection the experimentation on eros
the construction of the ring on venus
and the opening of the ringgate network
led this crew through life-changing
adventures for the first three seasons
because of their familiarity with all
things protomolecule and also secretly
avasarala's hope that they might mess
things up and then broadcast the dangers
of transiting through the rings to the
entire solar system they set off for
illus in season 4 to mediate a dispute
between a group of belters and an earth
corporation who were both claiming
rights to the new planet and even though
they inadvertently took some active
proto-molecule along with them which
caused a lot of problems when the planet
started to turn back on much to
abasara's dismay they were successful
and that pretty much meant there was no
stopping a mass exodus of humanity
through the ring gates to these new
systems
season 5 picked up after their return
and this new situation created problems
for two of the factions that exist in
our solar system mars had been focused
on a generations long project to
terraform its planet with so many
habitable planets beyond the ring gates
this project no longer made sense also
it put the belters in a situation where
a lot of them aren't able to make the
transition back to living on a planet
with gravity and most of the work they
do is in extracting resources which are
now going to be plentiful on all these
new worlds so a lot of their population
won't be able to benefit from this shift
and their way of life will be coming to
an end and the conflict becomes this new
economic and political situation that's
a direct result of the ringgate's
opening there's a climate where a man
like marco and narrows could emerge in
the belt to try to take power for
himself and a man on mars who sees this
as an opportunity to break away and
recreate this vision of mars in his own
image on one of those new planets he's
able to bring important people in to
back his cause and they're able to take
control of a lot of high-tech martian
military hardware while all of this is
cooking in the background the crew of
the rasa nante just needs a break and at
the beginning of season 5 while the
rasanante is being repaired at taiko's
station the characters all split up for
different reasons holden stays on tycho
with the ship and after learning from
monica that someone is doing research
with the proto-molecule at a secret
facility in the belt he tries to get to
the bottom of it he's worried because
the gate builders were wiped out by the
unknown aggressors and now humans are
using the ring network as if nothing
happened they're moving to these worlds
overlooking the inherent danger amos
gets word that his surrogate mother on
earth has passed away lydia helped
protect him in his violent childhood
after his real mother died so he decides
to return to pay his respects and make
sure she died of natural causes he
travels alone and on the journey we see
him process his grief through violence
when he fights a group of thugs that are
shaking down the other passengers he
encounters avasarala on luna on the way
and returns to his old neighborhood in
baltimore he meets lydia's partner and
is satisfied that she died naturally but
is upset to learn that he's losing his
house now that she's gone he goes to
meet with his childhood friend eric and
we learn that his real name is actually
timmy he killed the real amos burton to
save eric's life and in exchange he got
a new identity and a way off the planet
with the condition that he would never
return they're able to work it out
though eric agrees to take care of
charles and amos decides to make one
last stop before he leaves earth for
good he heads to the high security
prison known as the pit where they're
holding clarissa mal who at one point he
was all about executing because she
tried to kill them but who he also later
formed a friendship with on the way back
from the slow zone alex decides to take
this time to return to mars for an
ill-advised reunion with his ex-wife and
son when that goes poorly he connects
with bobby who he learns is
investigating a conspiracy of black
market martian weapon smuggling she's
working for abasarala and has discovered
that someone high up in the martian
chain of command is in on it when alex
recognizes admiral soviter he decides to
go and try to talk to him using his past
military service and his celebrity of
being the first pilot to successfully
transit a ring he brushes him off saying
that he pilots a stolen martian ship
under an earther captain but his
lieutenant emily babbage is more
receptive or at least she pretends to be
in order to try to gather information
about his time on illus in the proto
molecule he learns that she's shipping
out with soviter on the bar keith and
bobby wants to follow them because she
thinks they'll be delivering contraband
with the help of fred johnson naomi
locates her son and tells holden that
she needs to go find him alone she
explains that she was able to get away
from marco but couldn't save her son
phillip now she's afraid that he'll end
up dead so she needs to at least try to
help him she goes to palace station
where she meets up with her old belter
crewmates and tells them that she wants
to see philip they have a reunion that
doesn't go well and she goes back to her
ship to return to taiko where they knock
her out and then take her back to
marco's ship the pella which is
noticeably a martian light frigate where
she essentially becomes his prisoner and
we know that marco has created the free
navy we saw her son phillip for the
first time at the end of season four in
a raid on mars where the free navy
acquired stealth technology at the end
of that season into the beginning of the
fifth we saw that their plan has been
put in motion and while the rossi crew
is all spread out across the solar
system their asteroid attack hits earth
three asteroids coated with stealth
composites were able to get past the
earth's defenses and hit the surface at
the same time on tycho station fred
johnson is assassinated and the active
proto-molecule sample he had in his
possession is stolen the secretary
general of the un is killed and after
the third rock hits marco and the free
navy take responsibility holden tries to
chase down the proto-molecule sample but
the ship that's carrying it is able to
eject it in a torpedo during their
exchange that goes unnoticed bobby and
alex realized that there are ships being
delivered from mars to the free navy but
then they get spotted and have to dump
the razorback's core to avoid getting
hit by a missile from there they lose
the bar keith amos is able to survive
the asteroid impact because he's
underground visiting clarissa in the pit
after the attack they're able to escape
and start a long journey to find a ship
and get off the planet naomi tries to
connect with her son and makes an
attempt on marco's life that goes
unnoticed when philip intervenes faced
with no other options but to remain a
prisoner and to be separated from her
real family on the rossignonte she
chooses to make a hard vacuum transit
without a suit back to the ship she
arrived on killing her longtime friend
sin in the process when he tried to stop
her this looks like a suicide attempt
because they saw her go outside without
a suit but when she gets on board the
chet's mocha she realizes that she's on
a bomb that marco plans to use as bait
to destroy the ross and ante the ship
has been stripped of anything that might
be useful so she has to go to heroic
lengths just to get a message out to try
to stop her crew from coming to get her
she's eventually able to receive a
message from alex that says he's on his
way in the razorback and after putting
the ship in a spin to make docking
nearly impossible she has no choice but
to leave the ship without an air bottle
as she's making warning signals telling
them to stay away and running out of air
bobby swoops in in her suit to save her
when they get back to the razorback they
learn that alex had a stroke from the
high g maneuver during the approach and
he died as a result elsewhere germa had
become part of a polyamorous family that
crewed together after she left medina
station they recovered ashford's ship
the tynan and were eventually called to
join the free navy they did a crew
exchange of one of their husbands for
one of marco's crew who he wanted there
because he didn't really trust them
marco ordered her ships to destroy the
rasanante and she backs out at the last
minute turning on the free navy ships
they're able to destroy the koto and the
syrio maul which were both mcrn ships
but their husband who was on the pella
was killed in retaliation drummers saved
the rasanante in holden but half of her
remaining family abandoned her as a
result and at the end of the battle she
really has nowhere to go on luna
avasarala eventually makes peace with
the fact that her husband was killed in
the asteroid attacks she had been trying
to avoid retaliation that might push
normal belters towards marco's free navy
but was unable to stop an attack on
palestinian when follow-up attacks were
being discussed she resigned in protest
and was followed by several other
high-ranking members then she was
approached about a vote of no confidence
that was put forward for the acting
secretary general with an offer for her
to become the leader again holden and
naomi are reunited and make their way
back to luna amos and clarissa make it
to winnipesaukee and commandeer a ship
and dramatically shoot their way off the
planet everyone comes together on the
moon where they mourn the death of alex
and offer their support as an
independent ship in the fight against
the free navy while they're gathering
there marco is making a move for saul
gate they unleash a micro meteor attack
against the ships guarding the ring gate
and are able to take control with help
from the martian breakaway fleet in
medina station it's a victory that means
marco now controls the choke point to
all of the worlds beyond the gates and
can cut off access to the inner planets
by blocking their ring we learned that
sovietaire and the martians were
delivering the ships in exchange for the
proto-molecule sample and safe passage
through the laconia gate they used the
chaos that marco created for earth as a
distraction so they could move their
breakaway fleet out of seoul and into
laconia and then they created a
barricade by installing a minefield
behind their ring as he's getting ready
to transit the laconia gate he gets a
message from cortazar telling him that
the sample arrived safely and that
things are starting to happen on the
planet he explains how important this
mission will be how they have to be
perfect to babbage as their ship starts
their transit then it appears as though
time stops and the two of them come
under attack from an otherworldly
presence and i say that for lack of a
better way to describe what's happening
it looks familiar to what we saw when
elvie passed through the bullet on illus
and they are essentially blinked out of
existence the bar keith disappears in a
red cloud and the season ends with a
post-credits scene of an orbital
platform that looks like it came from
the gate builders above laconia
centuries of oppression and the promise
of easy atmosphere land and resources
created a situation where marco and the
free navy backed up by the breakaway
martian fleet could bring war to earth
and what's left of mars the average
belter might not agree with marco's
methods but they have no love for the
inner planets either and we saw an
example of that through drummer's family
who eventually made the tough decision
of joining him in the loss of fred
johnson and his faction of the opa takes
away that option the only path forward
is war because the free navy have
established a strong position that
they'll never let go of if marco can
retain his power avasarala finds herself
in charge of a planet that experienced
an attack that will likely take
generations to recover from if it can
recover at all she lost her husband in
the attack and will be under tremendous
pressure to turn things around at the
beginning of season six the ross ante
lost a member of their crew and took
clarissa on board for amos which is a
pretty uncomfortable situation
considering she killed a lot of people
in her quest to murder holden from the
trailer that's out there we know that
bobby will be coming on board too and
they might be without a pilot because
there's no indication they have someone
to take alex's place so that's where
we're at ahead of the final season the
final season at least for now season
five was important beyond the rise of
the free navy because we finally got to
learn more about the characters as
individuals it paid off a lot of things
related to naomi and amos that they had
been hinting at since the beginning now
that they're back together in season six
they can refocus their efforts on marco
but you have to wonder how what they
experienced will affect them and i think
that's a good place to leave things i
have several other videos about season 6
including trailer breakdowns and a
detailed video about the ending of
season 5 if you're still fuzzy on what
happened let me know in the comments
what you're hoping to see in the sixth
season and how you think it will all
come together if you want to talk book
spoilers please make sure to mark them
so we don't spoil things for people who
haven't read them please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already i'll be
doing tons of videos throughout the
season and thanks for watching i'll talk
to you soon